la case satec
dans les années 1960 le développement
des industries du bâtiment mounès les
artisans qui travaillent dans ce secteur
pour éviter leur disparition et les
aider l'état créé en 1961 la société des
deux techniques et de coopération plus
connu sous le nom de sa tech
elle met au point un plan type de maison
faisant appel à des techniques de
construction artisanale et utilisant des
matériaux très moderne pour l'époque
le parpaing le métal et les célèbres
naco modulable le plan de la cassa tech
permet de concevoir à moindre coût des
f5 et f6 la distribution intérieure
s'organise autour d'un séjour les
chambres étant disposés de part et
d'autre de cette pièce centrale
grande nouveauté cuisines et salles de
bains sont intégrés dans la maison
le modèle de base comporte en façade une
large varangue dont la toiture est
soutenu par deux tubes en métal avec la
casse satec la varangue jusque là
réservés aux grandes demeures créoles va
se démocratiser
concurrent direct des cases tomi pendant
plus de deux décennies
cet habitat moderne aux lignes
contemporaines rencontre un succès
indéniable auprès des milieux modestes
ou des classes moyennes
bien qu'aucune qu'à sa tête ne soit
encore protégés au titre des monuments
historiques
ces maisons symbolise au même titre que
la casse tommy larchitecture populaire
des années 1960 1970 à la réunion